le week end à la fierté pour nous à
l'e-commerce ainsi c'est un peu comme le
grand prix pour les gens de la rue lepic
la déception demeure vive pour se
tonifier de bord dans le village
l'annulation en catastrophe du défilé de
la fierté a été un coup dur pour ses
ventes l'achalandage qu'il anticipait a
été bien moindres l'année dernière il y
avait une marche quand même s'il avait
pas eu de parade et la marche avait
terminé dans le village ici sur la route
à tekken est ça l avait amené beaucoup
de gens évidemment à circuler dans les
villages donc là on n'a pas eu cette
manne un sentiment partagé par cette
employée d'un établissement voisin bah
on a eu un peu moins de monde que la
capri vue là je suis sûr que c'est plate
pour tf1 si je prépare depuis un air
malgré cette bourde le directeur général
de fierté montréal à l'intention de
demeurer en poste
non non non moi je ne songe pas à
démissionner hamachi la métare compte
garder moi j'ai des cages l'état tranche
des trams c'est pour ces administrations
donc ça sera à eux de décider quoi faire
avec moi c'est une erreur administrative
qui a forcé l'annulation de l'événement
des dizaines d'agents d'accueil embauché
pour le festival n'ont pas été affectés
à la sécurité du défilé c'est pas la
faute de la ville de montréal pour la
faute des policiers pas faux du
gouvernement du québec et il ya eu une
erreur d'organisation c'est malheureux
des organismes qui travaillent avec
fierté montréal souhaite une reddition
de compte on voit les seules
organisations phares son poste son post
mortem ses réflexions et tout pour
s'assurer videmment que ça se reproduise
pas au lendemain de ce fiasco
l'incompréhension chez les festivaliers
persistait j'ai pas vraiment fier cette
année de la tournure des événements
nettement s'était dit cela mais le monde
s'arrange sultan je céderai la
communauté peu importe ce qui arrive ça
se rassemblent save un comité a été mise
en place pour faire la lumière sur ce
qui s'est passé en fin de journée les
organisateurs ont rencontré la mairesse
valérie plantes pour qui comme plus
heures de nombreuses questions demeurent
entières ici et me lemieux radio canada
montréal